[Music]
hey guys it's very I'm bringing you the
faith of ginjury in the final season
supportive leagues trailer and a few
theories and predictions of mine Eng
will finally reunite with Arya Stark in
the season 8 premiere in episode Swan
and - he will forge weapons that are
jealous and since I'm expecting from
brain to go back in the past and find
out how to make Valyrian steel I'm also
expecting from gantry to forge Valyrian
steel swords again drivel later in
episode 3 fight alongside Arya John
another sin epic battle for Winterfell
against the night king and his army
Genji will also by my theory Gilligan -
a Baratheon ro Stormlands and vitória
but all that being said let's just jump
in dead starting with a quick recap
about injury injury the skilled
blacksmith and unacknowledged bastard
son of King Robert Baratheon after
escaping the massacre of Robert's utter
bastard Singh King's Landing
Ginji joins the Nights Watch where he
meets Arya Stark before getting captured
and traded multiple times
first the time Lannister at Harrenhal
then - the Brotherhood without banners
and finally - Stannis Baratheon on
Dragonstone after escaping from jurgen
stone with the help of sir Davos
Seaworth ginjury returns to King's
Landing and remains in hiding until
Davos returns for him he later company's
johnston north of the wall on a mission
to capture white to use as a bargaining
chip at the par Lincoln's landing with
the death of King Robert the massacre of
his other bastards the death of Robert
siblings friendly Stannis as well as
Stannis his daughter Sharon ginjuries
the last known living person house
Baratheon bloodline Genji now seems to
take pride in his brought in blood
carrying the Lannisters for killing his
father Robert and immediately informing
John's known that his Robert's bastard
son knowing his father and John's father
Evert best friends referring to Ned
Stark
his personal Warhammer features a design
of a stag's head with full antlers on
either side of the head socket the stag
being has brought in sigil thanks to the
season a trailer we know for a fact that
Genji will be Minerva in season 8
meaning that he'll story not with his
old friend Arya but this is not coming
unexpected having in mind a tourism and
fellow alguien G on your hand is heading
towards that vigil snowman
targaryen we know that those two will
certainly reunite in the very first
episode of the final season and it's
definitely going to be interesting to
see how the relationship will play out
about which I'll talk more later in this
video since the end of season 6 I've
been saying that Genji will play an
important role in the final season in my
opinion ginjury who is known as the
skilled blacksmith will be of a huge
importance in this last season as I'm
expecting from brain to find out how to
make Valyrian steel to his visions and
I'm also expecting from ginjury to be
the one capable of forging these swords
in the books ice was reforged by top
amant alcoholic master blacksmith who
moved to King's Landing years ago and to
whom Genji was apprenticed when ginjury
was old enough and I know Lord paid his
apprentice face so he could learn to be
a blacksmith he then took up work as an
apprentice blacksmith under table amon a
master weaponsmith forging high-end
armor and weapons for the nobility Genji
became very skilled in his own right and
heavy manual labor built him up into
strong young men ironically swinging a
heavy blacksmith's hammer much as Robert
once swung his Warhammer kenji worked
under table amount for ten years and
therefore if anyone could make these
swords it's definitely ginjury with the
night king being approximately two weeks
away from Winterfell and me the fact
that the night king will attack
Winterfell in Episode three again she
has only two episodes to forge as many
weapons as he can they're capable
killing White Walkers and her whites
however having in mind that ginjury has
so little time to make as much weapons
as it can the show will probably go with
Genji forging weapons out of journalists
rather than making Valyrian steel swords
simply because there's no time for that
but also because John mind huge amounts
of journalists in Dragonstone last
season and is bringing it to Winterfell
so yeah ginjuries here most likely
making weapons out of chicken glass
which is a long Valyrian steel one of
the two known substances capable killing
White Walkers Center White's ginger will
be making battle axes Halbert spikes
hatchets and daggers out of it for the
night King arrives even FL ginger will
of course fight as well although he has
no formal combat training ginjuries
remarkable skill with a hammer both as a
weapon and a tool much like his father
Robert while escaping from King's
Landing he effortlessly killed two
curious gold cloaks at a Warhammer
having inherited his father's incredible
strength
however again she will not be able to
use it effectively against White's my
Walkers hammer
would stop them for a second but it
cannot kill them because remember only
journalists Emily rien still can kill
them sunless ginjury had some journalist
spikes on his hammer it's pretty much
useless Center de hunk again learned is
the hard way McHugh's ganges hammer
against whites he knocked a few but he
did not kill them so the concrete was
switched back to his regular staggers
again she will definitely be very
important in his last season let me
remind you that back in the third season
when Mel Sanjay bought ginjury from the
Brotherhood without banners
Ginji disappointed that Brotherhood sold
him to me Oh Sandra said that he thought
he was one of them he said that he
thought he was the part of the
Brotherhood without banners on which Mel
Sanjay replied with you're more than
they are ever going to be because of you
the Kings will rise and fall I'm a
varied ml Sanjay but this was pointing
on his blood which used for blood ritual
but what if there's more than that what
if Mel San Jim is the true meaning of
that what if the Kings were literally
rise and fall because of him as a result
of his own acts good for an example
Gimmes recalls the fall of the knight
king by forging Valyrian steel swords
are making journalist weapons which one
will be used to put an end to the night
king or could he buy himself and buy his
hammer makes some of the Kings rights in
some fall literally killing some and
supporting other it's an interesting
thought this Monsanto statement is
definitely foreshadowing something huge
and I can't wait to see how that kind of
the prophecy will play out regarding
injuries endgame aside he making Kings
rise and fall my prediction is that
he'll get legitimized either by John or
Danny he'll rule Stormlands and he will
marry Arya Stark and ginjury the
talented blacksmith and bastard of King
Robert Baratheon finally reappeared in
the show in season 7 many fans have you
began jury being back on the scene as a
sign that his father's promise to arias
fodder in season 1 might finally be
fulfilled remember back in the very
first episode in Winterfell crates
Robert Baratheon expressed his desire
that his son should marry Ned's daughter
to line their houses once and for all
Robert was talking about Joffrey who he
thought was his son and Ed's daughter
Sansa this never happened and therefore
how stark a house Baratheon have not
been joined yet however huge amount of
fans think that this marriage might
finally happen in the form of Roberts
only son ginjury and Ned's other
daughter Arya or young Genji formed a
special bond
way back when they were traveling
together northern Kings Road there's one
memorable scene that re-engages shared
that might have a shadow that those two
could become family one day when Genji
told aria
that he's never had a family someone to
take care of him aria said I could be
your family
Ginji back then believed that him an
area could never be together considering
that she's a highborn daughter of Lord
Eddard Stark
well he on the other hand is just a
bastard son kenji later found out who is
father truly is King Robert Baratheon
having in mind that our is imminent
valve algún G on the other hand is
heading towards it with Jon Snow
maintained a Targaryen those two will
most certainly reunite in the very first
episode of the final season but many
fans believe re-engage we will end up
together many fans are convinced that
Aria would never settle down and have
children and I understand them after all
that sutorius said herself regarding her
future however what we also need to
understand is that Game of Thrones is
full of irony
Aria never wanted to be a lady or a
sister saying Salvage dreamed of
marrying a handsome young man giving him
children and living a happy life
wouldn't be kind of Roenick seeing aria
a girl who never wanted any of that
getting what sense always wanted we all
expect Aria to either die in a battle or
to live out her days as an assassin
adventurer and that's why probably
neither this will happen it'll be too
predictable her getting a happy ending
and living her life as the proper lady
she never wanted to be able to be a huge
twist for a character so Aria will most
likely end up marrying injury and live
other days raising their children in a
castle I have a son you have a daughter
will join our houses is the quote that's
always been on my mind obviously back
then Robert was implying that sense and
Joffrey should bet but we all know how
it all worked out for them however this
in my opinion foreshadows conjoined area
during Baratheon start houses once and
for all some fans even claimed that
Georgia morning show a nurse thought of
our Engine G while riding this
particular scene considering how they
tend to twist words around or he does
have feelings for Genji which was made
clear when she told him that he can be
your family now the target has finally
returned to Winterfell and Genji on the
other hand has not only returned to the
series but is also heading to Winterfell
it just seems they're meant to end up
together I can definitely see them
living their days out peacefully in
storms end with their children I'm sure
most of you are wondering how could they
live in a castle that belongs to house
Baratheon considering the injuries a
bastard son and therefore he's not
allowed to hurt his father's lands or
titles well there are two possibilities
one is a ginjury super son or Robert
Baratheon as there's a theory in which
his mother is actually Cersei Lannister
and the second possibility is him simply
getting legitimized by John
or Danny ginji's a bastard son of the
late King Robert Baratheon and with no
living Baratheon's left in the series he
will most likely get legitimized by
Danny if he agrees to bend the knee and
swear his loyalty to her which ginjury
will most likely do I understand that
there are some are you thinking that
Danny legitimizing injury would make no
sense some of you think that she by
doing that she would be creating a
potential rival for the Iron Throne and
even a ginjury personally is not a
threat some of you think he could either
marry an ambitious woman or have an
ambitious child well Danny statement say
otherwise
Danny as well as John stated multiple
times throughout season seven the child
should not be guilty for their father's
sins and doings if they allow Tyrion to
become her most trusted advisor whose
father did more crimes to House
Targaryen than Robert did I don't see
why the any would not legitimate injury
if he will bend the knee and sir his
loyalty to her and his becoming Lord
brothy on ginjury wooden hair storms end
and Ari will most likely be his lady
whilst Ned was killed in season one
which set of the events for the series I
cannot help but think that net for share
of his marriage when he told Arya that
she will marry a high Lord and rule his
castle
just as Robert wanted back in the first
season the house Baratheon and Stark
will probably join through his son and
his daughter just not all the ones he
and Ned thought very heavy guys ginji's
fate in season eight with some events
being confirmed and neither just
prediction same theories mine
in conclusion gingival definitely play
an important role in the great war
against the night king and in my opinion
he will survive Game of Thrones
get legitimized as a true Baratheon and
marry Arya Stark of Winterfell feel free
to leave your thoughts about all of this
in the comment section down below do
like interspace through season eight and
his endgame or do you not and if you
think I missed something please let me
know and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see you in the next one
peace